mais quand même posé la question est ce
qui vous est arrivé de voler dans un
magasin parce que normalement c'est elle
qui dit oui
soit quand j'étais jeune j'irai tatiana
ce cas chose que pas très fin
voilà pas très légal eh bien figurez
vous mesdames messieurs que ces vols ont
des répercussions sur les prix des
articles que vous achetez c'est un sujet
de 90 minutes enquête une perte pour
l'hypermarché mais aussi pour le client
car le magasin répercute ce manque à
gagner sur d'autres produits
résultat chaque année vous payez 215
euros en plus à la caisse pour compenser
les vols sans compter le prix de
certains articles qui s'envole
rien que pour les protéger comme ici au
rayon maquillage tous les produits se
vendent sous blister pour pouvoir être
protégé ça nous oblige à se poser la
question de la pertinence de vente des
produits semblent hyster qui du coup
serait beaucoup moins cher de l'ordre de
deux fois moins cher donc voilà alors en
2014 on a des chiffres les vols en
magasin ont coûté près de 3 5 milliards
d'euros au distributeur français soit
124 euros par foyer et par an c'est à
dire que c'est bibi qui paye c'est nous
moi j'ai une petite question à ce que
vous payez bien caroline ithurbide c'est
cette émission mais je vais lui
défalquer je fais mes courses tout seul
depuis mes 17 ans donc 215 euros elle me
doit 3870 euros carrosse attire le
regard
je prends pas les chèques vacances
rennes manque à gagner cet impact et moi
j'ai j'ignorais en fait qu'on répercute
seuls les vols la fin là l'argent de ses
vols sur les produits a bon goût c'est
vous le saviez âmes en oui de toute
façon ils connaissent très exactement le
taux de vols dans les magasins
donc il le répercute sur le prix moi la
grande surprise en regardant les études
là dessus ça a été de voir que les
français dans le monde
ils sont quasiment dans le top 3 des
vertueux c'est à dire si les mois
collard % voilà rien et donc les
allemands dont je pensais que la
discipline nerfs il serait super sérieux
ben non ils sont vachement loin ça veut
dire qu'ils volent beaucoup plus que
nous les français
alors nous pourtant t'appeler la table
mais quand même ou alors on a des
vigiles qui ce qui dissuade bouge pas
une oreille
damien alors pour un premier temps je
tiens à vous préciser que je ne fais pas
partie de ceux qui commettent ses
filouteries parce que je trouve ça
potentiellement abject dont je fais la
direction d'agfa exactement ensuite
c'est vrai qu'avant il y avait les
caissières vous savez qui était quelque
part le dernier rempart avec les vigiles
pour repérer si il y avait et dès lors
s'en aille a toujours tout
malheureusement oui mais de plus en plus
on a recours à des bornes enregistreuse
assez automatiques voilà où les clients
peuvent eux-mêmes scanner le code-barres
est aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui est
tentant finalement c'est de prendre le
code-barres de veau carottes et de le
coller sur un jeu vidéo à la mode qui
coûtent la peau des fesses comme ça ce
sera moins cher et vous pourrez passer
sans problème j'ai l'impression que
quand vous dites ça vous l'avez fait ça
c'est ma jeune lozada mieres ça veut
peut-être arriver là tiens voilà tu vas
prendre l'oseille pp à part ça c'est des
filouteries à regarder puis il ya bien
sûr non qu'est ce que vous en pensez
tatiana les policiers ont dévoilé un
portrait robot du parss evola
supermarché alors à une grande blonde à
travailler c'est que de la télé non
alors la personne entre 18 ans et 30 ans
à 40% ou damien tués dans la course à l
es dedans et alors c'est un homme à plus
de 65% damien tu es toujours dans la cua
pauvre et isolée
ça fait un moment que tu as plus 25 ans
j'adore mais le sait et et en plus ils
volent pour revendre auparavant il a
décidé de voler la personne a décidé de
voler pour revendre et notamment cette
personne-là volerait pendant les
périodes de noël et comme on sait que
dany je peux vous dire que le parfait
voleurs ressemblerait à damier c'est
vrai lorsque j'allais à des bourses
étudiantes
il m'est arrivé peut-être d'aller au
rayon parfum et m'asperger un petit peu
de parfum pour vous avez bavé les
échantillons pour sa gestion bien sûr
c'est pas du vol ça sympa mais j'ai
l'impression d'être un gros rebelles de
citer un oui bah c'est vrai que
nouvelles habitations du funk qui est
assez relative quand même bon on a posé
la question à nos téléspectateurs
la répercussion des vols sur les prix en
supermarché ce que voudrait ça normal ou
scandaleux vous trouvez ça scandaleux à
78% alors les prix augmentent en cas de
vol mais ça dépend sur quel voleur on
tombe aussi
il est tombé mais y'a même pas lu de ce
que je trouve une question j'ai
malheureusement il est tombé chaos